but there the claims that Starfield is
still being worked on by about 250
deaths that's about half of the
pre-launched team and is as big as some
AAA Studios as for what they're working
on there are multiple updates planned
and some DLC with Todd Howard saying in
interview with wed you're talking to me
but there are 450 people here we still
have people that work on Fallout 76 we
have about 250 on Starfield these only
exist because of all of those people and
us working together that's why games are
so big there are so many moving parts
and interesting things that people will
find that comes from everybody here for
a good comparison 76 only had about 200
people working on it at any given time I
believe Starfield was like 500 which is
again a lot of people for any AAA scale
there are studos that are of course
bigger usually for live service games
but that is like but that is a lot of
people